aquí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
imaginen que son las 9 de la noche de un
día cualquiera y viene el delivery una
docena de empanadas
a la hora llega el chico con la moto con
la bici como se hace ahora con sólo ocho
de esas empanadas
eso mismo pasa en la industria
alimenticia hoy un tercio de los
alimentos que en el camino 1500 camiones
de alimentos se tiran a la basura todos
los días
cuando tenía 20 años luego un paso
frustrado frustrado y ximo por la
carrera de arquitectura comencé
estuvieren publicidad sin saber porque
no tenía idea de lo que es la publicidad
me controlé yo en esos escritorios
nuevos proyectores computadoras
compañeros con palabras como target
bridge campañas publicitarias y tantos
otros conceptos que no me permitían a mí
escuchar lo que dentro mío empezaba a
sonar querer una sociedad más justa
me sentía vacío pero como encontrarme en
la comodidad un escritorio si a mí lo
que me incomoda ver es la pobreza
hay sobre che guevara en un shopping
entonces tenía dos caminos o vale
abandonar nuevamente una carrera para
incursionar en una carrera más legal o
social o tomaba todo lo que estas
disciplinas me podían dar para aplicarlo
de lleno en pos de un impacto positivo
así cuando luego de muchos años de
búsqueda de trabajo llega a mi vida el
capítulo banco de alimentos la fundación
banco de alimentos recuperó alimentos de
la industria aptos para el consumo
humano los clasifica los controles con
profesionales en inocuidad alimentaria y
los destina a 200 organizaciones
sociales comúnmente llamados comedores
merenderos llegando a casi 18 mil
personas de manera directa acá en la
ciudad de córdoba
de esta manera la fundación trabaja
sobre tres tipos de impactos
el primero eléctrico y social en un
mundo donde hay más de 800 millones de
personas con hambre según la fao
el segundo impacto un impacto económico
porque por supuesto que desperdiciaron
alimentos provoca un costo en la empresa
que se traslada directamente el precio
de la góndola al que cada uno de ustedes
paga
y el tercer impacto un impacto ecológico
porque el enterramiento sanitario de
estos alimentos produce gases de efecto
invernadero por encima del propio
automóvil
ahora yo les quiero preguntar
levanten la mano por favor cuanto de los
que estén acá como alguna vez un yogur
bajo y qué harían si les digo que 300
mil vasitos de yogur se están por tirar
a la basura en mi primer semana de
trabajo en la fundación recuerdo que
recibimos el llamado una empresa láctea
muy grande tenían casi 100 palés de
yogurt que estaban por desperdiciar
porque la fecha de vencimiento del yogur
era demasiado corta para sus clientes
la respuesta estaba en nosotros en la
fundación en el equipo en mover cielo y
tierra para que cada uno de esos botes
de yogur terminara en la mesa un
merendero terminará siendo consumido por
un chico que tal vez en su vida había
probado un yogurt
recientemente en la localidad balcarce
una empresa muy grande de papas fritas
congeladas tenía 3 millones de kilo de
papas que sabía que no voy a utilizar
resulta que esta papa se no cumplía el
estándar de calidad de sabor que la
empresa necesitaba para su producto
pero ustedes pueden pensar la cantidad
de otros platos de comida que se podrían
realizar con 3 millones de kilo de papas
120 camiones debían salir desde balcarce
a encontrar una solución o encontrarse
en una olla en un comedor
lo que tenemos que saber es que no basta
solamente con llenar la panza sino que
se trate de conseguir alimentos que de
otra manera estas 200 organizaciones no
podrían conseguir
en el mes de abril con el equipo fuimos
a un comedor pancita llenas llegamos con
el equipo con los autos calles de tierra
hasta llegaron se los citó
quien es mucho más grande que este
escenario
los pisos de tierra los techos de chapa
había algunos niños ya jugando los
caballetes los tablones en el patio por
supuesto había un chancho un caballo
y al fondo por allá a la derecha había
una parrilla de 1 metro de ancho con un
fierro para mover las brasas
nosotros llevamos 500 hamburguesas
la mitad del equipo
se ha dispuesto a jugar con las primeras
niñas
la otra mitad estaba preparando las
balanzas y los centímetros para pensar y
para medir a los beneficiarios y yo
había quedado ahí
arbitrariamente designado al frente de
esas parrillas a cocinar esas 500
hamburguesas el hijo de graciela la
referente del lugar muy amablemente me
sugería que celebrara es que tenía razón
en 15 minutos en ese salón citó había
150 chicos esperando su hamburguesa
esperando lo que probablemente iba a ser
la mejor cena de su semana
fueron dos horas para el frente de esa
parrilla poniendo y sacando hamburguesas
poniendo y sacando hamburguesa en la
mano me dolían las tenían realmente que
llamadas pero que más me dolía era
imaginar cómo era la vida de esos chicos
el resto de la semana que comían aquí
colegio iban o aquí jugaban en esas
calles inundadas del mes de abril
es impracticable para el referente un
comedor o para hacer en este caso
abordar una alimentación una
alimentación saludable en un contexto de
tantas urgencias porque cocinaron una
tortilla de verduras como lo pueda hacer
julián como lo puede hacer camila es
relativamente sencillo en una cocina a
gas natural pero para 150
la olla donde se coloca el agua para
hervir y se pone un paquete de fideos
acompañado durante años el crecimiento
de estas comunidades
en invierno una tarde extra para cagarse
de frío
fuimos a visitar un merendero la
realidad del contexto no cambia mucho el
anterior la diferencia que este
merendero había entre 60 y 70 chicos
solamente
los pisos de tierra tras techos de chapa
los caballetes los tablones también en
el patio abierta anchos y caballos pre
esta vez en el fondo hay un calentador a
leña con dos joyas una de aceite para
freír la tortilla y otra de mate cocido
los chicos hacen una cola hasta llegar
al lugar donde una de las madres con un
cucharón les harían más de cocción su
taza
el chico posteriormente recibía la
tortilla un potecito de yogur y se iba a
sentar con el resto de sus compañeros
porque les cuento que en la pobreza y el
invierno se pasa así con un mate cocido
una taza de mate cocido que se abraza se
agarra muy fuerte con las manos para que
el vapor de la tasa suba y nos acaricia
las mejillas
el tema que se mate cosido se termina y
el chico vuelve la verdad y la verdad
que cinco cuadras de tu casa o de la mía
hoy en argentina una de cada tres
personas se termina elementos en un
comedor mientras para nosotros parece
totalmente normal comer una carne de la
cacerola con nuestra familia
la verdad que una de cada tres alimentos
también en un basural ya sea porque la
fecha de vencimiento es corta porque no
cumplen procesos de color de tamaño
porque no tuvo éxito en la venta
alimentos aptos para el consumo humano
se terminan desperdiciando sin afectar
bien absoluto nuestra percepción del día
a día
ustedes se dan cuenta que evitar el
desperdicio de alimentos puede
solucionar el hambre
lo pueden ver lo quieren ver
todos nosotros somos unos privilegiados
de algún modo el vapor del eta se nos ha
acompañado
yo les pregunto cuántos los que están
acá levanten la mano por favor tiene
acceso a internet
porque les comento que en el mundo de
verdad una de cada dos personas no
cuenta con este acceso
cuantos de los que están acá tiene un
título universitario pudo ir a una
universidad
a cuantos leyeron un cuento alguna vez
porque a cuatro de cada diez personas
esto nunca les pasó
como 2 de cada 10 tiene que compartir un
colchón para dormir y 17 cada 100 no le
festejan los últimos cumpleaños según
algunos datos de la boca
si ustedes no les pasó de corazón me
alegro que así sea pero los invito a
levantarse a salir de la como de esos
escritorios los invito buscar ahí
adentro que le está moviendo el hambre
es uno de los muchos o miles de
problemas que tiene esta sociedad yo no
sé cuál te mueve a vos pero hace algo
cuando nosotros reconocemos las
oportunidades que tenemos primero somos
un poquito más felices pero cuando
nosotros trabajamos en pos de aquellas
personas que no tuvieron estas
oportunidades el mundo se vuelve un
poquitito menos injusto
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y